I don't have anything very structured
but I just want to get the conversation
going the first question I have for you
guys is tell me about a time you had to
problem solve so I want you to talk to
the person next to you and discuss when
you head to problem solve today girls
who do I have any volunteers for some
good examples how about on the rats roof
okay go ahead what do you do okay thanks
what about you but everybody my building
has an iphone we all like each other's
charges so solid oh I good shows being
at your own a new
that's a good idea anyone else anyway I
have over the Raspberry Pi activity did
everything work flawlessly yeah
oh nice was it hard figuring out where
to put that line of code
good how about for processing I need
good examples yes in the back
how'd you figure that out great on my
next question is how would you improve
the camera that you built today so this
time turn to someone behind you or in
front of you and tell them what you
would do differently
girls who do I have any volunteers from
the second row yes
yeah hey swell what kind of material do
you think you would use did any of you
guys play with Alex's lenses do you see
how protective they were and a lot of
professional photographers they break
them all the time so the other ways to
make it more structured and prevent it
from breaking any other ideas said the
case yeah yeah a lot easier to take
photos a good like the moment you see
like the stuff is you get that exactly
yeah that's a really good point anyone
else yeah I try to accept our something
the camera around and looking at image
on the screen it was for smooth links
but it's not jerky images
do you guys remember how in the code it
said you had code for displaying that
image and then you had code for
displaying the or capturing the picture
that you took when you press the button
so when you have that code for capturing
the image when it's displaying on the
screen it's actually taking that image
and then displaying it to you so that's
a lot of work for a computer to do
versus just um I think Gavin actually
had looked at that what were your idea
is what would you have done so there's a
way that you can just write to memory
instead of those different types of
areas which ran versus card SD cards
less so you can save it into your
cash and then throw that screen without
it should be fast see the volunteers are
thinking about the stuff to the last
question I have for you is tell me about
an Instagram filter that you change from
the original instructions so this time
turn to someone next to you but someone
different so you haven't talked to yet
girls who okay how about from the third
row what did you guys change with your
filters any volunteers did you guys just
keep it the same the whole time no would
you do oh you can both go
oh nice did anyone else do the image
effects change oh nice one person back
there um what about from over here what
did you guys do with the it's Graham
filters yeah Oh neat cool the RGB values
yeah yeah you too nice to be turned
everything except the color you click
done integrase no one to turn it into
turn just the color you click on in
black oh how nice those are all really
great ideas um so this concludes the
program I hope you guys had a wonderful
time and learned about things that you
wouldn't normally think about when you
think of computer coding and engineering
there were a ton of people all the
volunteers in the morning and then the
ones in the afternoon and our keynote
speakers so they are in the room next
door but let's give them a round of
applause for you period and you guys
probably caught on to this but most of
us work at MIT Lincoln Laboratory I do
ocean robotics there and I hope you got
a chance to talk to your volunteers and
hear about what they do at the lab we do
all sorts of things and solidworks also
sponsored this and MIT OpenCourseWare
have any of you guys heard of that raise
your hand if you have oh not too many of
you good so MIT OpenCourseWare is online
curriculum so if you guys want to get
this code we're publishing it online so
you can play more with it and get the
software and all the instructions we
also have a curriculum in wearable
technology so you can check that out too
and all this information will be sent to
you in an email and we also have a
Facebook page it's just girls who build
and a Twitter account and i'll be
posting all the material and photos from
this workshop on those websites so with
that i have a bunch of fun demos for you
guys we have 3d scanning and
photogrammetry and a light field camera
in the research area so you can rotate
around the stations and ask questions
and talk to the volunteers we also have
the computer still set up so you have a
little bit of time to keep playing with
the code and the cameras so in
conclusion thank you all for coming and
feel free to come up to me and ask me
more about camera technology we'd happy
to tell you about other fun projects you
can do thank you guys